et donc on va parler aujourd'hui de la
géographie du terrorisme mais le texte
est vraiment passionnant et ça va nous
permettre de faire aussi un peu de
géographie parce que
finalement on en fait pas beaucoup et de
parler d'eux c'est quoi la géographie
qu'est ce que la démarche géographique
ce que ça peut apporter aux fenêtres de
travail voilà de quoi on va parler
l'approchent géographique du terrorisme
question de méthode donc ici on va être
vraiment sûr la caisse que la
construction d'un objet d'étude vous
allez voir il ya plein d'infos
intéressantes qui vont arriver plein de
choses auxquelles on n'aurait pas
forcément pensé
c'est pas vraiment finalement une
vérification d'hypothèses ici le disent
on est vraiment sur des questions de
construction d'objets de définition il
ya quand même des informations qui vont
transparaître mais à la première lecture
j'ai adoré cet article est donc ici
comme vous le voyez bien l'article
il est de daniel dory qui est maître de
conférences à l'université de la
rochelle et hervé théry directeur de
recherche émérite au cnrs professeur de
l'université de sao paulo ils vont nous
parler de ça d'une manière très très
sympa et franchement moi qui donne le
cours de géographie en secondaire je
trouve que l'article est super bien
foutu parce que ça nous permet vraiment
de faire la démarche géographiques
telles que on la présente au cours alors
en quelques lignes c'est quoi la
démarche géographique de mon premier
lieu tu va regarder un petit peu des
répartitions dans l'espace en deuxième
lieu tu vas essayer de faire des
corrélations entre ces répartitions là
et d'autres variables spatiale est ici
le font très bien dans l'article et de
manière très très limpide et
troisièmement essaie d'expliquer tout ça
quoi évidemment donc d'amener un petit
peu de la théorie
alors je vais pas vous passer tout
l'article à l'écran parce qu'il ya
toujours la question des droits j'ai pas
les droits donc on dit je pense qu'en
diffusant quelques extraits quelques
petites choses à vous montrer et en
lisant le reste là il ya moins de
problèmes quand même alors là projet au
graphique du terrorisme est une démarche
relativement récente est actuellement en
phase de consolidation en effet ce n'est
qu'à la suite des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 que des géographes se
sont véritablement intéressé aux aspects
territoriaux de cette modalité
particules y'a de communication violente
voilà il faut quand on travaille sur un
objet très dur comme celui là un petit
peu aussi dépassionner le débat
et considérer le thé aux rimes de
terrorisme pour ce qu'il est et ici
voilà utilise comme un moyen une
modalité de communication violente
l'émergence progressive d'un champ de
recherche spécialisé à l'intersection
entre les terrorismes study et la
géographie suppose un certain nombre de
conditions parmi les plus importantes il
ya bien entendu la question
définitionnelle qu'est ce que le
terrorisme et tu vas voir la queue en
fonction de ce qu'on considère être du
terrorisme ou pas on va avoir finalement
des réalités qui sont différentes et ça
c'est super important mais je pense tva
pourra peut-être nous en dire plus mais
dans n'importe quelle science la façon
dont tu vas te définir les objets mais
certainement sciences sociales ça va
conditionner tout le reste est tu peux
très vite créer un artefact alors pour
rappel un artefact ben c'est quelque
chose qui n'existe et qui n'existerait
pas sans le chercheur c'est le chercheur
qui crée finalement un objet
qui n'a pas forcément une correspondance
dans le réel si tu sais tu crées des
objets qui n'existent pas par définition
qui sont mal mal pensée mal conçu c'est
très vite problématique parce que pluton
travail et à mettre au bac
arrive à définir le terrorisme en tout
cas il y aura des éléments définition
qui vont venir
ensuite il fallait procéder à un long
travail d'appropriation critique des
travaux issus des terrorismes study ce
dans le but de disposer d'un socle de
connaissances et d'hypothèses
mobilisables dans une perspective
géographique donc là c'est un petit peu
l'état de l'art donc l'exploration
qu'ils vont faire et ça dont n'importe
quel travail tu dois regarder aussi ce
qui a été fait sinon tu risques de
réinventer l'eau chaude ou de te
fourvoyé de partir sur une fausse piste
donc ça c'est aussi un aspect d'une
démarche scientifique de sciences
sociales qu'ils mettent en place dans
cet article enfin dans la mesure comme
on le montrera plus loin où la recherche
géographique n'est véritablement fait
compte que lorsqu'elle s'inscrit dans un
projet d'élucidation l'espace-temps du
terrorisme l'acquisition de solides
connaissances en matière d'histoire du
terrorisme s'est également avérée
indispensable
et donc là directement un petit peu le
programme
de dix neuf prochaines pages et j'ai
envie de dire si tu te dis ah ben non
moi je cherchais pas ça vraiment
chercher pas une définition du
terrorisme - travail méthodologique sur
la définition du terrorisme bah voila tu
passes ton chemin qu'ont quand tu fais
tes études quand tu fais des travaux des
recherches voilà tu dois un petit peu
aussi sélectionné et sinon tu risques de
trop lire 1 c'est un gros problème je
pense aussi bon moi j'ai jamais été
doctorants mais quand tu vois les
doctorants qui partagent leurs
expériences sur les réseaux sociaux
voilà tu te rends compte que tu es très
vite s'y remet sur monet si tu veux tout
l'iran disant oui ça pourra m'être utile
qu'aux non tu dois vraiment ciblé sur ce
qui sera utile c'est donc sur ces bases
qu'il était nécessaire d'évoquer
brièvement que s'est construite notre
démarche dix ans analyse et l'intérieur
les territorialités du complexe
terroristes on nous centrant sur ces
espaces temps successifs au moyen d'un
dispositif carte graphique innovant et
en constant perfectionnement notre
propos est donc ici essentiellement
méthodologique donnant à voir les
sources les outils et quelques résultats
d'un des chantiers les plus passionnants
de la recherche géographique
contemporaine et j'ai envie de le dire
un bon là c'est leur bébé mais c'est un
article critique moi aussi m'a beaucoup
plu parce que voilà je me suis dit là
j'ai pas perdu mon temps j'ai vraiment
appris des choses intéressantes notre
démarche en cette phase de notre
recherche consiste principalement en une
exploitation cartographique de la global
terrorisme database l'ass qui vont
appeler après la ddte i dont le reste de
l'article ce qui nécessite quelques
éclaircissements factuel méthodologique
oui je m'excuse aussi pour les
bafouilles mans bon déjà c'est la
première fois que je ressens trim depuis
deux mois mais en plus j'ai fait deux
balades guidées et ce matin ce matin et
cet après midi donc j'ai parlé toute la
journée donc là est un peu la fatigue
qui s'installe mais ça va aller est très
motivé à faire ce stream la gtd jeudi
rajouter des en répertorie les
événements considérés comme relevant du
terrorisme dans le monde depuis
1970 1970 elle est basée à l'université
du maryland est régulièrement alimenté
par le consortium start qui bénéficient
d'un soutien direct du gouvernement des
états unis donc là c'est intéressant
parce que tu as aussi des éléments qui
permettent de faire une critique des
sources alors je peux pas la faire ici
parce que je suis pas compétent en
matière géopolitique pour la faire mais
voilà c'est aussi dans un souci de
transparence que tu dois tout balancer
dont on articles comme ça c'est très
clair et on peut te critiquer en fait là
c'est un travail intellectuel manseng
ces données issues principalement
d'informations de presse sur les
incidents on va là est-ce qu'il ya pas
des billets aussi un de choses qui
seraient pas relayées dans la presse
pour epinal y ait au niveau
méthodologique ont été synthétisés
depuis 2012 dans le global terrorism and
ex rapport élaboré en collaboration avec
l'institute of economic and peace qui va
ainsi des actuellement il s'agit de la
meilleure base de données disponibles
incluant temps les incidents liés à des
conflits internes à chaque pays que ce
qui relève du terrorisme international
et vous allez voir que l'enjeu vient
d'être résumé dans cette phrase bon déjà
il ya une chose que je vais dire
préalablement un certain moment dans les
sciences sociales ce qui est un peu
problématique tu vois c'est que t'as pas
toujours les données que tu voudrais
avoir et c'est parfois assez difficile
d'en trouver et donc ça c'est un peu un
problème c'est que comme tu peux pas
recourir à des expérimentations et créer
des conditions bon voila tu vois tu sais
pas recréer un accélérateur de
particules l'équivalent pour le
terrorisme quoi le terrorisme s'est
défait qui se passe dans la société tu
peux pas leur créer quoi sinon il ya un
petit problème aussi déontologiques et
donc ça c'est un petit peu aussi une des
limites des sciences sociales c'est que
tu es limité sur le matériel que tu peux
observer quoi puisque tu peux pas le
crétois même alors c'est peut-être naïve
de ma part parce que moi je suis pas du
tout dans l'actif dans les sciences dans
les sciences naturelles mais voilà une
expérience chimique tu peux tu peux la
craie et tu peux créer ton matériel pour
la réaliser bon ben voilà en sciences
sociales tu es toujours limitée par le
matériel qui existent je sais pas
forcément créer bon parfois tu peux le
créer mais dans ce cas là ça va être
compliqué donc ça c'est un facteur qui
est quand même assez limitant par contre
ce qui était intéressant dans cette
phrase
incluant temps les incidents liés à des
conflits internes à chaque pays que ceux
qui relèvent du terrorisme international
c'est que terrorisme ça va être un truc
qui va être utilisé et on revient sur la
question de la définition mais dans des
contextes politiques pour aussi des
enjeux géopolitiques style poutine va
dire que dans tel territoire de la
russie tu as du terrorisme mais en fait
c'est juste des groupes qui luttent qui
luttent contre l'autoritarisme de
poutine par exemple tu vois dans toutes
les sociétés un certain moment tu as un
pouvoir autoritaire qui peut s'installer
et le pouvoir autoritaire va dire ben
voilà on est face à du terrorisme alors
que c'est juste une lutte politique pour
le pouvoir et donc il faut bien
distinguer du terrorisme qui veut
instaurer à des fins politiques aussi un
climat de terreur où tu vas toucher des
civils là c'est un terrorisme voilà qui
touche des civils d'un terrorisme
politique même si de l'autre terrorisme
et lui aussi politique mais là l'enjeu
est directement politique dans le sens
où c'est pas la terreur que tu veux
instaurer tu veut renverser le régime
qui est en place et du coup alors désolé
pour
cet exemple grossier mais lors de la
seconde guerre mondiale tu aurais pu
considérer les allemands considéré sans
doute la résistance comme du terrorisme
et donc c'est pour ça que c'est super
important tu vois de distinguer de ce
qui relève d'un conflit interne à chaque
pays de ce qui relève du terrorisme
international coi ou là on veut créer un
climat un climat de terreur
cependant tout comme les autres sources
similaire sa fiabilité donc cette
fameuse base de données qu'ils vont
utiliser dépend de la valeur de ces
définitions envoyé le dirait un 6 sur ce
point des procédés de codification des
lacunes dans le recueil la disponibilité
de l'information
donc voila moi ce que j'aime bien c'est
qu'ils sont assez conscients du billet
est ici et un autre auteur il en résulte
que lorsque l'on travaille comme nous
l'avons fait sur des données agrégées de
la gtd tels que l'on peut les
télécharger sur le site du consortium
sans pouvoir parfois filtré de façon
véritablement satisfaisante les cas
douteux ou clairement non terroriste les
cartes obtenus sont à envisager plus
comme des indications de tendance et de
distribution générale que comme la
représentation exacte d'un phénomène
dont contours sont parfaitement
maîtrisés
il est cependant à noter et ce point est
important pour notre propos qu'une étude
empirique détaillées concernant le
terrorisme en inde conclut certes à une
sous représentation des incidents dans
la base de données donc voilà ça c'est
un billet aussi il y aurait plus de
phénomènes que ce qui est remonté mais
observe néanmoins que la distribution
spatiale des incidents répertoriés
correspond assez bien à celle qui se
dégage de base de données plus inclusive
donc autrement dit ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette base de
données qu'ils vont utiliser n'est pas
parfaite mais comme eux ils l'utilisent
merci tva pour le lien comme eux ils
vont l'utiliser pour une distribution
spatiale et que cette distribution
spatiale dans un cas particulier dans un
contexte particulier qui est celui de
l'ain du terrorisme en inde on a
constaté que la base de données avait
une distribution assez proche de ce qui
était une réelle évaluation des actes
terroristes en inde alors je ne sais pas
si je me suis bien fait comprendre ben
voila moi ce que j'aime bien c'est que
c'est très transparent ce qu'ils font en
tournée il ya un goût moustiques juste à
côté de la webcam je suis pour le no
kill sauf le moustique et je les ai pas
eus
traitement statistique et cartographique
de base le terrorisme dans le monde donc
là on rentre vraiment dans le coeur de
l'article
le point de départ de notre analyse a
consisté à l'eba à l'élaborer une
première représentation d'ensemble de la
distribution spatiale du terrorisme dans
le monde donc pour ceux qui veulent
vraiment faire là c'est de la géographie
au secondaire il y en a dans le tchat eh
bien voyez c'est d'abord la première
chose comme je vous raconte en classe la
première chose c'est de vraiment décrire
la distribution spatiale
quelle est la répartition dans l'espace
du phénomène que l'on entend étudier et
on aboutit ainsi à la carte de la figure
1 alors je vais vous l'affiché voilà
donc ici je rappelle la figure 1 qui
inclut l'ensemble des actes répertoriés
donc là c'est vraiment
une mise en en carte des données de la
base de données utilisée la gtd
chaque cercle donc là on est de 1970 à
2019 chaque cercle proportionnelle à
leur nombre situant précisément les
actes puisqu'il se géo référencées en
longitude et latitude dans la base de
données donc ça c'est génial parce que
tu peux directement le mettre sur ton
système d'information géographique pour
le spécialisés donc on pourrait utiliser
bon si vous ne connaissez pas un petit
peu la géographie et les outils qu'on
utilise il ya un bon on utilise des
systèmes d'information géographique donc
en fait où les informations sont géo
référencées le plus connu ces argiles
et donc il ya des versions gratuites
dargis ce qui nous permettrait par
exemple de télécharger la base de
données puisque comme tva l'a fait on a
le lien télécharger nous mêmes les
données et puis les projeter sur le
système d'information géographique et là
tu as vraiment intervenants tout la
répartition pour travailler à
différentes échelles parce que bon le
problème d'une carte statique comme
celle qui est proposée ici tu peut
zoomer mais tu auras pas vraiment la
répartition par exemple au sein d'un
pays mais si tu l'avais télécharger sur
ton et si j'ai à ce moment là tu sais le
faire quoi ce qui est vraiment sympa
quoi nous n'avons retenu que les lieux
où se sont produits plus de dix d'entre
eux donc en plus il ya une sélection si
tu as eu un acte on l'a pas retenu le
seul que nous avons choisie pour éviter
de polluer la carte avec des cas
statistiquement non significatif on
constate d'abord que contrairement à ce
qui est trop souvent affirmé et ça
j'aime bien parce qu on déconstruit des
représentations
le terrorisme n'affecte pas le monde
entier ouais tu vois ya des endroits où
il n'ya pas n'est pas de terrorisme moi
j'ai la carte en plus petits puisque jeu
là je suis sur le texte mais si je dis
pas de bêtises en australie quasi rien
nouvelle zélande les cazéens dans le sud
de l'afrique quasi rien si je me trompe
pas ce que la carte est un tout petit
sur l'écran et moi je suis sur le texte
mais qu'il sous tend à se consacrent se
concentrer de façon aléatoire dans
certains territoires ces derniers
pouvant être identifiés au moyen de la
construction d' enveloppe ou zone de
prévalence dont il sera question plus
loin moi je sais pas du tout ce que
c'est un de découvre avec vous la
signification du barycentre localisée au
sud de l'egypte sur cette carte sera
également expliqué par la suite bon même
s'il explique par la suite en fait le
barycentre ça c'est un petit peu comme
le point de gravité est donc là il ya un
calcul sans doute statistiques qui est
fait je suis je suis désolé de ne pas
pouvoir les expliquer peut-être que tva
a avancé un peu plus mais voilà c'est
comme si c'est vraiment le point qui
résume qui moyenne hills qui centralise
l'ensemble des actes alors sur cette
carte si il n'est pas très intéressant
mais bon c'est intéressant d'en parler
maintenant donc le barycentre localisée
au sud de l'egypte sur cette carte sera
également expliqué par la suite cette
représentation
initial de la spatialité du recours à
cette technique de guerre irrégulière
asymétrique est totale donc voilà une
autre définition et là on se bat sur
daury 2022 donc on pourra la voir dans
la bibliographie de quoi il s'agit donc
une guerre le terrorisme est une guerre
irrégulière asymétrique est totale oui
parce que dans certains cas quand c'est
une guerre enfin quand le terrorisme est
utilisé à des fins politiques internes
le terrorisme ses larmes du plus pauvres
ou du faible généralement
ensuite fait l'objet de deux traitements
complémentaires le premier concernant la
temporalité donc c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure sur la carte qui est
affichée actuellement les grands tu peux
te rien dire parce que les phénomènes se
sont étalés sur des décennies que
finalement tu as plus les mêmes
phénomènes est ici tu dis que c'est la
même chose alors que c'est c'est des
choses qui ont bougé quoi donc ça c'est
une première chose
le deuxième s'attachant à la spécificité
du fait terroristes et là on va revenir
sur la définition et tva là on va aussi
faire une distinction entre ce qui entre
ce qui est vraiment une finalité de
politique interne en une finalité plus
global qui est d'instaurer aussi la
terreur à des fins politiques donc ce
qui est un peu la différence qui est un
peu différent d'un côté tu va attaquer
des cibles stratégiques entre guillemets
militaire ou policière tu vois où des
outils de gouvernement style ben voila
je reprends mon exemple grossier de la
seconde guerre mondiale thé résistants
tu fais péter les voies ferrées tout ça
et de l'autre côté tu veux instaurer un
climat de terreur tu va détourner un
avion et voilà et ainsi de suite
la figure 2 et on va y passer
la figure 2 permet d'appréhender les
configurations l'efi configurations
spatiales successives du recours au
terrorisme au cours du temps donc ça
c'est intéressant parce que tu vois que
le phénomène y bouge
où figure la distribution temporelle des
attentats au cours des années pour
lesquels on dispose de données dans la
gtd il est à noter que cette
périodisation fourni un premier cadre à
notre projet scientifique visant la
compréhension de l'espace temps du
terrorisme en intégrant une démarche
unique des propositions de périodisation
et de régionalisation de ce phénomène en
outre ce travail entre en résonance avec
d'autres tentatives de périodisation
issus des terrorismes se dit dont celle
des vagues dun vite rappaz rapporte
ainsi qu'on peut le constater la
distribution spatiale du terrorisme
évolue vite c'est pour ça que la
première figure la première carte était
pas très intéressante outre le fait de
constater que le terrorisme n'est pas
distribué parfaitement spatialement
comme on le voit sur la figure 2
par exemple par la quasi absence d' acte
terroriste
entre 2011 et 2018 en amérique latine
alors qu'ils étaient bien visibles sur
la figure 1 lors de la première période
de 1970 à 1979 le terrorisme affecté
principalement l'europe et quelques pays
d'amérique latine dont la deuxième donc
de 1979 à 1991 il y a encore présent
mais apparaît aussi avec force
particulière en amérique centrale et du
sud colombie et pérou avec les farc et
le sentier lumineux ainsi qu'en asie on
a un don sri lanka les années 90 et le
début des années 2000 de 1991 à 2004
sont plus calmes avec la multiplication
des actes bien sûr différent et menées
par des groupes divers au moyen orient
et en asie des années 2004 2011 suivi
notamment suite notamment à l'invasion
de l'afghanistan en 2001 et surtout de
l'irak en 2003 qui se continue en 2011
2018 en y ajoutant l'afrique somalie
nigeria mali donc on voit qu'il ya une
évolution de la répartition et donc ça
il faut le prendre en compte parce que
sinon tu risques
bah d'analysé des choses qui sont quand
même grossièrement différentes
une fois ces éléments de périodisation
et de régionalisation à qui il s'agit de
s'intéresser aux critères permettant de
dégager la spécificité du faits
terroristes par rapport aux autres
modalités de violence principalement
politique a donc là c'est bien
distinguer quel est l'objet politique
qui est visé dans les deux cas c'est
toujours politique mais où en tout cas
globalement mais voilà les données sur
lesquelles reposent les guerres
précédentes concernant appelons
l'ensemble des actes un clou dans la gtd
qu'ils fournissent par conséquent une
idée assez exacte de la distribution
spatiale de la violence politique dans
le monde mais pour appréhender la
localisation différentiel du fait
terroristes il est nécessaire de
discriminer ce qui relève spéciquement
du terrorisme à partir de l'identité des
victimes est-ce que c'est des civils au
sens large de l'autre forme majeure de
violence politique qui s'attaque
prioritairement à des cibles militaires
policières et ou impliqués dans la
gestion étatique des territoires un
certainement quand un régime autoritaire
qui te presse comment tu fais pour le
renverser voilà tu es obligé de recourir
au terrorisme
donc le terrorisme peut être dans
certains cas me semble-t-il légitime ou
plus légitime
d'autant plus si on vise des cibles
matérielles
cette dernière modalité révèle des
formes de guérilla et s'inscrit
généralement dans des mains des
dynamiques insurrectionnelle dans la
figure 3 on a comparé
la distribution de la mortalité due au
terrorisme et celles qui résultent
d'action de guérir et donc là on a une
distinction et on voit que la carte
votre tellement évolué par rapport à ce
qu'on voyait
sur les figures précédente cette carte
est instructive car elle fournit une
première indication non seulement de la
proportion des actes de différentes
natures à turckheim qui a des espaces
dans lesquels c'est assez
disproportionnée si on prend l'algérie
tu vois que les deux parties du cercle
sont quand même très inégalitaire pareil
au nigeria par contre après tu as
d'autres pays où tu vois que la
proportion est plus équivalent tous ces
mêmes l'autre forme de terrorisme qui
prend le dessus comme par exemple en
amérique centrale mais je m'avance peut
être de trop par rapport à ce qu'ils
vont dire donc ici la prédominance du
terrorisme en afrique somalie et en
amérique du nord est remarquable alors
que la part des victimes ali dit et
l'identité fonctionnel donc ce que lui
la paix ils appellent ce qu'ils
appellent l'identité fonctionnelle de
membres de la police des armes et divers
fonctionnaires étatique un don qui
représente le pouvoir en place est
beaucoup plus importante en europe est
généralement au moyen orient
cette distinction portant sur la nature
des actes à un grand intérêt pour
l'analyse des situations géopolitiques
nationales et régionales comme on le
verra par la suite parce qu'ici en fait
ils ne sont juste occupé qu'à construire
l'objet ils vont passer à des analyses
régionales qui sont autrement plus
intéressante que ce convoi jusqu'à
présent
parmi les exemples possibles ou prix
villers et le privilégié rond deux cas
celui de la triple frontière sahélienne
niger mali burkina faso et celui de
l'afghanistan
le premier illustre une avancées
méthodologiques consistant en la
recherche des barycentre et en
l'observation leurs déplacements donc si
vous reprenez le stream maintenant le
barycentre c'est simplement quand tu
prends un ensemble d'observations
géographique d'avoir le centre de
gravité de ces observations de cette
répartition
les barycentre dans quelque sorte les
centres de gravité des attentats dans
l'espace concerné pondérée par la
fréquence relative de leurs
manifestations en chaque lieu ils
permettent de cerner de manière efficace
le déplacement d'un procès
insurrectionnelle en cours sur la figure
4 de l'histogramme
l'histogramme permet de distinguer la
spécificité locale les deux promus de
deux premiers épisodes et la croissance
spectaculaire de la violence notamment
terroristes à partir de 2012 donc là on
est vraiment sur cette région l'un des
cercles proportionnelle indique le
nombre d'actes ressent chaque lieux
identifiés dans la base en latitude et
longitude donc sans les contraintes de
la maille administratif donc ça c'est
bien parce que parfois en géographie le
problème c'est que ces informations
elles sont définies par unité est ce qu
on appelle souvent les minutes
nomenclature des unités des statistiques
territoriales non des unités
territoriales statistiques et donc voilà
selon ted redécoupage régionaux battue
va avoir une représentation mais parfois
elles veulent rien dire tandis qu'ici
c'est chaque point et géo référencées et
donc là ça me donne la localisation
exacte est donc ça c'est cool
leurs nuances de gris est donné par la
période au cours de laquelle ils ont été
commis la discrétisation et ont été
faites au vu de l'histogramme pour
distinguer à l'effet de la révolte
touareg au niger et mali
90,96 la révolte touareg suivante 2007
2019 et ses suites les années
immédiatement antérieur et postérieur au
début de l'opération serval en 2013 la
dynamique de la complexité dans les
années suivantes
2019 date des dernières données
disponibles au moment de la réalisation
de ce travail qui a fait l'objet
d'une première publication
alors ce qui est très intéressant je
trouve c'est que voilà il te donne les
critères qu'ils ont utilisés pour créer
leurs catégories statistiques
et moi j'aime bien cette transparence
dans les articles parce que tu les as
pas toujours hélas tu comprend bien
pourquoi ils ont pris ses repères là
alors après on pourrait dire oui mais
bon prendre ses repères là c'est un
petit peu construire les données bon il
ya toujours un moment où tes choix vont
influencer la manière dont les choses
seront représentés graphiquement ou
cartographique mans
mais après c'est des questions de
méthodologie 1 comme disait bourdieu
voilà moi j'ai donné ma méthodologie
quoi que c'était moyennement vrai ça
mais ici te donne de métrologie tu
pourrais très bien dit ouais bon moi je
trouve que 2013 2019 ça va pas tu
pourrais prendre d'autres critères
l'important je pense que quand il ya un
article voilà qui se veut scientifique
c'est qu'il nous donne toutes les clés
que si on voulait
refaire l'analyse on arriverait sur les
mêmes résultats et on peut critiquer
l'analyse étant donné qu'on a tous les
éléments pour la critiquer c'est pas
toujours le cas quand
pour mieux voir le déplacement de
l'activité insurrectionnelle au cours du
temps nous avons donc eu recours aux
calculs des barycentre en utilisant l'un
des modules du logiciel de cartographie
carte est donné
cela permet de percevoir notamment le
déplacement du centre de la violence en
direction du sud au cours des dernières
années et la tendance à la
transnationalisation que le djihadisme
introduit dans la zone dont le foyer sud
est du niger lie à boko haram est une
autre expression son poids et est et
pardon pour le moment trop limité pour
déplacer sensiblement le barycentre est
donc en effet on voit la croix blanche
qui est remontée vers le nord puis après
on est reparti vers l'ouest pour
redescendre vers le sud est en effet on
va dans cette zone des trois frontières
et on va comprendre pourquoi après est
donc là tu vois les barycentre par
rapport à la remarque de tva tout à
l'heure qui me disait au niveau du
planisphère savent rien dire parce que
si tu prends un planisphère centré sur
l'amérique fera pas le même barycentre
mais là ça a du sens ça a du sens et
vous allez voir après c'est même assez
intéressant ce qui se passe par la suite
cette représentation permet en outre de
constater la menace directe est
croissante non puisqu'on voit aussi
l'augmentation de la violence qui pèse
sur le burkina faso qui ici est au sud
maillon essentiel de la progression de
la mouvance jihadiste vers les pays du
golfe de guinée est donc avec cette
seule carte 1 j'ai envie de dire que
l'analyse géographique justifie son
utilité puisque aujourd'hui on est dans
une société qui dit ariste c'est mon
grand regret mais ce n'est que mon avis
et donc à quoi peut servir une aire
géographique mais à savoir exactement où
vont être les problèmes futurs et tu vas
voir on en a pas fini avec ça
reste est à mettre en rapport les
concentrations d'acte terroriste dans
certaines parties du burkina faso avec
des facteurs qui peuvent en expliquer à
localisation outre la poussée générale
vers le sud déjà mentionné nous en
proposons 3 donc ça c'est intéressant
parce que ils ont constaté qu'elles
étaient les répartitions et surtout ici
comment elle veut elle évolué dans le
temps
maintenant ils vont nous donner des
corrélations pourquoi dans ces zones là
pourquoi ça a évolué dans ces zones là
et donc ça c'est vraiment le pour moi le
deuxième temps la démarche scientifique
c'est quand tu fais des corrélations
entre différentes dimensions de l'espace
ils nous disent premier facteur l'effet
des frontières
quand tu arrives dans une zone
transfrontalière
elle a des spécificités cette zone
transfrontalière a une frontière créer
un espace conte alliés qui est différent
de l'espace qui n'est pas frontalier ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit en 5e
chez nous la proximité des réserves
naturelles alors on n'a pas de carte qui
permettent de les voir mais en effet
dans ces zones là il ya des réserves
naturelles et puis à la présence de
gisements d'or exploitée par des mines
industrielles ou des orpailleurs
artisanaux
donc tu vois déjà ici on préfère une
belle carte de synthèse où on vient
mettre les informations qui sont là on
vient placer les frontières existant on
pourrait utiliser un figuré qui
viendraient renforcer
ses frontières vraiment avec je sais pas
moi comme le zoom qui te permettrait de
voir vraiment l'espace frontalier
les réserves naturelles qui les
représentent et puis les gisements d'or
qui représente toulousain figurer
ponctuelles et là tu as déjà une très
belle carte de synthèse qui explique
déjà certaines choses quoique en tout
cas qui explique pourquoi il ya un
glissement vers le sud des actes
terroristes et rien que pour ça moi
j'aime bien cet article parce que là on
a vraiment fait de la
géographie huawei tu vois ça c'est
vraiment convaincant et autant à
l'échelle mondiale c'est pourri que là
c'est vraiment convaincant quoi
je trouve surtout avec ce qui va venir
les deux premiers se manifeste dans
l'angle nord-est et sud est du pays un
bon nombre d'actes terroristes se
situant dans et autour des réserves
naturelles surtout frontalières où leurs
auteurs trouvent refuge pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils vont là bas parce que la réserve
naturelle à les grandes et peuvent se
cacher quoi et qui sont en outre qu'elle
est moins contrôlés que sais-je sans
doute ce type d'élément qui vit qui
interviennent le troisième est bien
visible au nord où un grand nombre
d'actes se situe entre la réserve sylvo
pastorale et de faune du sahel au nord
de dori et un groupe de mines d'or
industriel ou artisanal ces dernières
semblent donc favorisé la multiplication
des actes terroristes sans doute dans la
mesure où elle contribue directement ou
par des intermédiaires volontairement ou
pas au financement des groupes
djihadistes alors qui est directement
tous levés ben voilà bien financer la
guérilla
active dans la zone possibilité de
refuge et sources de financement se
conjugue donc dans ces lieux facilitant
la propagation vers le sud d'une
dynamique insurrectionnel dont les
protagonistes recours ainsi au
terrorisme enfin et le fait nous nous
paraissent suffisamment suffit
significatifs pour être mentionnée ici
au cours de la réalisation de cette
étude notre démarche a malheureusement
entre parenthèses reçu une tragique
validation en pays qu
en effet dans la nuit du 4 au 5 juin
2021 la localité de solana a été le lieu
du plus important massacre de
populations civiles commis au burkina
faso environ 160 morts or ce gros
village se trouve dans le prolongement
de la dernière flèche indiquant les plus
récents déplacements du barycentre
donc on est vraiment dans le
prolongement
ici je sais pas si vous allez voir mon
curseur si non
je pense pas nous aller voir mon curseur
mais bon vous savez
l'observer par vous même
or seulement se trouve dans le
prolongement de la dernière flèche
indiquant le plus récent déplacement du
baril cendres dont il a été question
antérieurement de manière inattendue
notre travail prenait donc un trac un
trait de caractère en quelque sorte
prédictif et son utilité dépasser le
seul aspect scientifique dans la mesure
où l'analyse d'une telle situation
géopolitique mouvante n'intéresse en
principe pas exclusivement des
chercheurs académiques et donc voilà ce
qu'on reproche souvent aux océans
sociale de ne pas être utile bas ici une
démarche en géographie permet de de
prédire et 2 1 peut piloter aussi une
intervention
c'est d'ailleurs à ces questionnements à
ce que ce que des travaux scientifiques
doivent être utilisés comme ça
l'eba la seconde avancées
méthodologiques repose sur la mise en
lumière des enveloppes ou périmètre qui
englobe les localisations des actes nous
avons montré la fécondité de cette
innovation en procédant parfois à chaud
à l'analyse du carcan la reconquête de
kaboul par les talibans le 15 août 2021
le classer vraiment de l'actualité très
fraîche a été une défaite majeure pour
les états unis leurs alliés et leurs
vassaux au-delà des enjeux géopolitiques
à court et moyen terme il est important
de comprendre la logique territoriale
qui a conduit à ce résultat
dans cette perspective nous avons
cherché à représenter l'évolution du
processus insurrectionnel qui débute en
2001 à la suite de l'invention de
l'afghanistan par des forces de l'otan
en réponse aux attentats du 11 septembre
2001 voilà pourquoi ce qui commence à en
2001 analyser les données pour
l'afghanistan parce que ils partent
l'intervention des forces de l'otan ceci
en recourant toujours aux données de la
global terrorisme date à bize complété
par diverses sources journalistiques
dont la lfp pour localiser des incidents
récents n'ont encore inclus dans la gtd
qui au moment de la réalisation de cette
recherche ne couvrait pas les années
postérieures à 2019 ce qui est embêtant
étant donné que j'essaie de comprendre
l'actualité plus la plus récente après
ça pose question con de la validité de
des remontées de delà de la fp mais bon
voilà c'est toujours le problème des
sciences sociales c'est la remontée des
données
comment être sûr que c'est fiable à 100%
et si c'est un petit peu voilà des
sources secondaires comme des données
secondaires qu'ils utilisent c'est pas
des données de première main que tu as
créé tout en
mettant en oeuvre les acquis des travaux
pardon aujourd'hui la même chose non je
n'ai pas j'ai pas lu ce pardon mettant
en oeuvre les acquis de travaux
antérieurs on a distingué les actes
strictement terroristes s'attaquant
prioritairement à des cibles civiles des
actions de guérilla bon sens l'a bien
compris ainsi que ceux attribués aux
talibans différencier des actions imputé
ou revendiquées par l'état islamique au
corps à son corps hassan qui apparaît
seulement en terrain afghan en 2014
avant de consolider sa présence vers
2015 pour pouvoir pleinement évaluer la
signification des cartes produites à
partir des données ainsi traités il
convient de rappeler quelques faits
concernant la létalité comparer des
incidents ainsi les talibans qui ont tué
environ 43 mille deux cents personnes
durant cette période se distingue par la
relativement faible létalité par acte
très rarement plus de 13 morts par
incident ce qui correspond bien à une
des caractéristiques de la guérilla qui
prévilégie la multiplication des
opérations de harcèlement sur des
portions de plus en plus étendue du
territoire par rapport à des actes
terroristes dont le fort impact
médiatique est généralement liée à un
nombre élevé de victimes
pour donc ici il revient sur leur
typologie mais avec un autre indicateur
qui est finalement le nombre de victimes
par la qualité des victimes ce qu'ils
avaient fait précédemment ce qui regarde
s étaient des civils ou si c'était des
forces armées ou policière pour ce qui
est de l'état islamique qui a causé la
mort d'environ 2800 victimes entre 2014
et 2019 la configuration est tout autre
car il s'agit d'une part d'une
organisation qui se livre avant tout au
terrorisme à partir de ses bastions de
kaboul et de djalalabad en d'autres et
d'autre part cette distribution
principalement urbaine rencontre du
caractère plus meurtrier de ces
attentats à partir de l'analyse comparée
de la mortalité produite par ces deux
organisations comprend aussi mieux les
logique stratégique contraste et qu'elle
mette en oeuvre au cours de la dernière
décennie et aussi les conditions dans
lesquelles l'état islamique poursuit son
activité terroriste après le 15 août
2021 pour comprendre enfin la dimension
territoriale de la dynamique
insurrectionnelle en afghanistan on a
construit quatre cartes de la figure 5
hop je l'intention ici est double
comparé d'une part le profil spatiale
des talibans et celui d' état islamique
au khorassan corazon khorassan je ne
sais pas et permettre une analyse fine
de la part des actes terroristes et de
des guides de guérilla perpétrés par
chaque organisation
le fait majeur que montrent ces cartes
et le tréport contraste entre l'emprise
au sol des talibans qui met en oeuvre
une stratégie nationale et nationalistes
et celle de lui pour qu'il organise en
lesquin front du jihâd
parmi d'autres envisagé dans une
perspective plus globale les cartes
localisent leurs actions montrent ces
logiques différentes avec une
remarquable efficacité
en effet l'état islamique qui apparaît
surtout comme une organisation
terroriste dont le périmètre d'action se
structure autour des villes de kaboul et
de djalalabad votre bien sûr les deux
cartes duo
avec quelques excroissance plus au nord
qui mérite des explications détaillées
ne trouvant pas leur place ici c'est
bien dommage parce que voilà ça c'est la
démarche géographique tu comprend très
vite que là on est dans des milieux
urbains où ils ont leur siège et tout ça
mais et pourquoi est-ce qu'il y en a
dans le nord-est quand j'aurai bien aimé
qui détaille ça c'est un peu dommage que
qu'ils ne le fassent pas ici mais sans
doute qui aura une autre publication qui
viendra plus tard
mais une certaine de
l'aneth prééminence de kaboul comme lieu
d'attentats tient à la fois l'attention
ancien de lui dans la ville et à
l'impact médiatique maximal d'actions
ayant lieu dans cette capitale
donc on voit que l'état islamique
s'avisait n'est pas un renversement
forcément dû pouvoir en place mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose de beaucoup plus
globale et j'ai envie de dire de moins
concrets et précis
mais une certaine tendance à la
dissémination de la violence
attribuables à cette organisation
s'observe dans d'autres villes comme
kandahar important centre d'implantation
des talibans
ce constat se trouve renforcée lorsque
l'on procède au calcul des barycentre et
l'a7 ce point ce centre de gravité
géographique j'ai envie de dire apporte
toute sa puissance dans cette analyse en
effet dans les deux cas actes de
terrorisme et de guérilla le barycentre
se trouve à proximité de kaboul et cette
donnée est encore renforcée lorsque l'on
observe les pays med correspondant à
l'activité violente de ce groupe en
somme l'état islamique au corps hassan
et bien une entité terroriste à
l'implantation surtout urbaine ce qui se
confirmera après ou 2021 au cours de la
récente phase de son activité lorsqu il
ciblera presque exclusivement les
talibans et les chiites afghans tout
autre et bien entendu le profil spatiale
des talibans passons talibans qui
ressort des deux cartes du bas de cette
même figure dans ce cas tant les
attentats terroristes que les actions de
guérir à se distribuer sur l'ensemble du
territoire utile de l'afghanistan c'est
vraiment une guerre de prise de pouvoir
que mènent les talibans dans une
évidente intention de parvenir à un
contrôle aussi étendue que possible de
l'espace national et fait remarquable
les barycentre des actes terroristes de
guérilla se situe à peu près au même
endroit ce qui témoigne d'une cohérence
stratégique qui explique largement le
succès de l'insurrection voilà ils ont
ils ont étudié leur truc enfin les
périmètres correspondant aux différentes
formes de violences montrent que le
recours à la guérilla a été privilégiée
dans la dernière période du conflit où
il s'agissait de maîtriser
progressivement l'espace tout en
s'assurant au moins de la passivité
complaisante de secteur croissant de la
population
à partir de cet exemple il est aisé de
comprendre les implications pratiques et
théoriques de notre démarche visant aux
moyens de calcul des enveloppes à
établir une sorte d'empreinte spatiale
les différentes entités qui recourent au
terrorisme
cet aspect très souvent négligée dans la
littérature spécialisée traitant de la
caractérisation
dynamique des groupes terroristes
présente pourtant un grand intérêt dès
lors que l'on s'attache véritablement à
comprendre la nature des entités
violente que l'on étudie ou et au combat
voilà après on arrive au prolongement
mais voilà ça c'est vraiment un bel
article me semble-t-il parce que voilà
tu arrives pas avec une question est
forcément une réponse ici on offre sur
un plateau un outil pour étudier le
terrorisme maintenant reste à d'autres
chercheurs ou à ces mêmes chercheurs à
reprendre ces outils pour les pour
étudier le terrorisme dans d'autres
contextes dans d'autres pays tout
simplement
alors développement
prolongement pardon
une fois construit le socle de notre
démarche scientifique
je trouve très très parlante et pour un
non professionnel en tout cas de la
recherche géographique je trouve ça très
très puissants comme article c'est très
intéressant je pense d'ailleurs que je
vais leur est utilisé en classe alors
peut-être pas sur celui-là mais ça
serait peut-être même intéressant après
d'envoyer alors il faut voir en quelle
année je le ferai parce que avant on
pouvait faire la géopolitique en
cinquième et en sixième maintenant ça
devient compliqué de faire de la
géopolitique pur tu dois partir soit de
l'aménagement du territoire en 6e soit
des ressources en cinquième quoique avec
les mini les mines d'or qu'on a vu dans
le cas de du niger et du burkina faso
et du mali ça peut être ça peut être
pertinent mais voilà on pouvais je
pouvais en classe présenter ça aux
élèves et puis après leur demande et sur
base
de la base de données qui est proposé
ici de faire une analyse spatiale
d'un territoire par rapport au
terrorisme ça ça peut être très très
sympa quoi pas très sympa
l'objet n'est pas sympa mais je vire
l'étude est vraiment très intéressante
et là je pense que ça serait vraiment
percutant pour les élèves qui verrait
vraiment l'intérêt d'une démarche
géographique je pense après on peut pas
intéresser tout le monde évidemment
celui qui s'intéresse qu'à son cul
c'est plus compliqué il a été mis en
oeuvre et affiné au moyen de
l'exploration de différents thèmes
connexes ainsi et sans vouloir être
exhaustif on peut citer les deux
suivants d'abord la mise en rapport
cartographique de la localisation des
ethnies en afghanistan et au pakistan
avec l'activité terroriste assez sympa
hein parce que là ils viennent apporter
d'autres données qui va te permettre de
comprendre cette spatialisation ça c'est
vraiment une analyse géographique et
ensuite la relation alors là c'est
étonnant
la relation entre le tourisme surtout
internationale et le terrorisme alors on
comprend vite pourquoi mais on ne
s'attend pas directement au tourisme
cette problématique qui avait déjà fait
l'objet d'une réflexion préalable a
ensuite été enrichi par une exploitation
cartographique des données dans
plusieurs articles notamment à titre
d'illustration de cette relation parfois
étroite entre terrorisme et tourisme le
cas de l'égypte est particulièrement
éclairant la figure 6 c'est génial en
plus d'avoir les cartes dans l'article
comme ça hein pour un prof de géo c'est
vraiment un super article suis super
content qu'on est con et du sud à quoi
la figure si ce qui présente les deux
phases majeures de l'activité terroriste
dans ce pays séparés par les printemps
arabes et l'émergence de l'état
islamique permet de distinguer aussi par
le déplacement du barycentre du
périmètre d'action permet de les
distinguer aussi par le déplacement du
barycentre du périmètre d'action centré
sur les zones touristiques de la vallée
du nil
d'abord pour ceux conçus pour concerner
ensuite surtout outre le caire toujours
important la péninsule du sinaï où des
attaques contre le des touristes hôtel
avion russe en octobre 2015 participent
également significativement de la
stratégie des groupes djihadistes donc
le sinaï c'est la partie vraiment à
l'est de la carte on voit qu'il ya quand
même pas mal de choses qui se passent
recherche géographique sur le terrorisme
dont cet article présente sur tous les
aspects méthodologiques entre en
résonance avec des questions théoriques
et pratiques qui relèvent tant de
l'enrichissement de la démarche
géographique dans son ensemble que du
développement des études spécialisées
sur le terrorisme en conclusion il nous
paraît par conséquent utile d'évoquer
deux problématiques ou la rencontre des
questionnements propres à ces champs
disciplinaires paraît particulièrement
féconde la première a trait au processus
de la diffusion spatiale thèmes
classiques de la géographie et sujet de
première importance pour les terroristes
utilisent les exemples concernant la
zone sahélienne des trois frontières de
l'afghanistan et de l'egypte analyser
plus haut montre tout l'intérêt de notre
démarche cartographiques pour aborder un
thème classique des études sur le
terrorisme et à cet égard on se place
aussi dans le sillage de travaux
intérieurs qui ayant traité le sujet
avec des méthodes purement quantitatif
on rencontre des limites qu'il est
maintenant au moins partiellement
possible de surmonter
la deuxième problématique découle de la
nature essentiellement urbaine du fait
terroristes cette réalité sur laquelle
existe une abondante littérature à
laquelle il fait il est fait mention
dans un autre article de dori en 2019 et
dont nous avons foré une preuve
additionnelle en étudiant le cas du
brésil il ya d'autres publications
pourrait peut-être aller à prévoir de
quoi il s'agit de les lire de manière
diagonale de voir un petit peu en tout
cas les cartes il y en a ainsi l'on
travaille de la même manière en nous
présentant de nombreuses cartes c'est
très intéressant peut-être profond
approfondie en dépassant le simple
clivage urbain rural pour s'intéresser
au choix des cibles d'attaqués en
relation à divers variable qui
contribuent à la différenciation des
tissus urbains concrets pour illustrer
cet aspect dans la figure 7 la figure 7
nous avons mis en rapport les lieux des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 dans paris
intra muros avec un aspect de géographie
électorale des arrondissements parisiens
ça c'est intéressant parce que c'est
intéressant je veux dire pourquoi parce
que tu travailles à différentes échelles
il montre que leur leur méthodologie est
intéressante ou leur façon de faire est
intéressante à l'échelle régionale
nationale ne régional mais aussi local
et ça c'est vraiment chouette parce que
pour un prof de géo c'est toujours
difficile de faire comprendre aux élèves
que la géographie ça se fait à
différentes échelles et qu'une réalité à
une certaine échelle n'est pas une
réalité une autre échelle
donc là c'est intéressant de pouvoir
aussi transposer le modèle
j'ai envie de dire
partant du fait amplement établi et
répété par les terroristes eux-mêmes que
ces attaques répondaient au bombardement
ordonné par le président françois
hollande sur le territoire conquis
depuis 2014 par l'état islamique en irak
est rarement scié il nous a paru
intéressant d'inscrire les lieux des
attentats sur une carte représentant le
soutien dont a pu bénéficier françois
hollande lors de son élection dans les
différents arrondissements parisiens
et donc si on regarde la carte avant de
lire ce qu'il nous propose on voit que
je vais redescendre un peu que le vote
pour françois hollande au deuxième tour
des élections
présidentielles ont eu lieu dans des
arrondissements dans lesquels on avait
principalement voter pour lui en 2012
après on va voir ce qu'ils vont dire
mais pour moi ça ne veut strictement
rien dire ce serait même peut-être une
petite erreur écologique dans le sens
d'une erreur écologique c'est que tu va
attribuer des choses en fonction d'une
population sans savoir qui effectivement
comme elle est les acteurs voir ce
qu'ils vont dire à ce qu'ils vont dire
on critiquera après s'il ya lieu de que
ce soit critiqué
ce faisant on se proposait de tester
deux propositions théoriques d'abord
celle du caractère noé at war du choix
de l'emplacement des cibles visées lors
d'un acte terroriste en considérant que
ce qui importe ici et la nature des
lieux au moment de l'attentât
caractérisé par la crise la coexistence
de résidents locaux et de personnes à
l'identité similaire qui viennent pour
différentes raisons dans ces cas liés à
des pratiques associées au délassement
café-restaurant concert ensuite la
pertinence de l'insistance sur
l'identité vectorielle des victimes du
terrorisme étant donné que le ralenti
retentissement maximale de l'action est
assurée par la relation entre ces
victimes et les audiences principal ici
le gouvernement socialiste français de
ce mode de communication violente
or dans ce cas on constate une
association étroite entre les lieux des
attaques et des deux arrondissements où
la victoire de françois hollande fait
croiser entre lax dessiné par la
localisation des attentats correspond
remarquablement en outre à la limite de
cette terre de forte concentration du
vote socialiste de second tour fait
qu'il mériterait une exploration
détaillé qui sortent d'autres propos
actuels en revanche à partir de cette
carte on dispose d'un argument
supplémentaire pour plaider pour une
prise en compte minutieuse des
caractéristiques des lieux d'attentats
en associant les connaissances issues
des géographie urbaine électorale aux
résultats les plus prometteurs des
recherches actuelles sur le terrorisme
pour moi je trouve que ce qu'il propose
ici moi me convainc pas du tout
peut-être que j'ai pas tout compris où
il voulait en venir mais voilà
je trouve que là c'est vraiment des
interprétations abusives et que outre
c'est très puissant quand ils utilisent
des barycentre
outre ici voilà je trouve que tu
pourrais faire mille une coopération
différentes
et qui vont dans un sens ou dans un
autre on est franchement sceptique parce
que là c'est s'est pas autant les autres
analyse avait une force probante qui
cite pas c'est pour moi c'est pas une
preuve c'est juste des corrélations
cette analyse cartographique comme celle
des exemples antérieures permet donc une
meilleure vision spatiale du faits
terroristes de maintenance et je trouve
ça intéressant de travailler à l'échelle
d'une ville aussi ça c'est intéressant
mais ce qui aurait été peut-être plus
intéressant c'est de cartographier sur
cette carte là en tout cas tous les
lieux importants du divertissement tu
sais c'est comme il y avait eu le monde
diplomatique qu'avec vous avez peut-être
vu cette carte là à l'époque mon
pourrait peut-être aller voir si on la
retrouve pas après c'était les lieux de
manifestations elle et les lieux de
pouvoir et donc il a fait une carte vous
avez mais les deux couches pour montrer
que les manifestations généralement vont
aller là où il ya des lieux de pouvoir
et donc on aurait pu faire une course
comme ça mais voilà comme ça c'est un
peu sommaire
l'exercice a évidemment ses limites bon
merci mais il permet du moins de mettre
en évidence
les avantages de la géographie de la
cartographie pour ce qui fait de faire
apparaître des configurations
spatiales de très grande ampleur
éventuellement leur évolution dans le
temps cette approche ouvre en
l'occurrence la voie à une véritable
maïeutique elle fait naître c'est
l'origine étymologique du mot sous les
yeux du lecteur des images qui lui
permettent de prendre conscience de
façon synthétique de la complexité du
phénomène janvier reste ensuite à
revenir aux données pour expliquer ce
que la carte confirme les points et les
moments de concertation apparition
disparition ainsi que les problèmes
d'interprétation qu'elle suscite et donc
aussi une étape indispensable d'une
démarche faite d'allers retours autres
données traitement et l'interprétation
qui est au fondement d'une de la bonne
science bon moi je pense qu'il faut pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain parce
que cette dernière 4 même si elle ne
nous convainc pas et qu'on la trouve un
peu bizarre
et que des propositions il faut pas
oublier ici c'est ils ont pas il lui
montre un petit peu basses que peut
faire leurs propositions méthodologiques
d'utiliser ces enveloppes
mais sans plus un donc voilà